well american consumers do know how
inflation is eating into their
pocketbooks and that spells bad news for
the economy and obviously the
president's approval ratings uh let's
bring in senior political analyst brit
hume
with a look at this good evening brett
you know
i tell you this energy process
and this administration's policy on it
uh seems to fly in the face of trying to
get gas prices down but what are your
thoughts
well it looks to me as this is an
administration that was willing to
sacrifice a lot on the altar of of
moving away from carbon-based
fuels
and
you know gasoline obviously oil coal
natural gas all those
in the interest of trying to save the
planet and they're seem perfectly
prepared to let consumers pay higher
prices perhaps ever higher prices uh
toward that end
so and the consequence of that bread i
think is politically
you know even if inflation in other
areas of the economy subsides
if people are still paying these
sky-high gasoline prices and other fuel
prices they're going to the feeling is
going to be that this administration
brought us inflation and it's here to
stay yeah not good politically right and
you look at those approval numbers and
they've been taking a dive he's
obviously had a success the president
has in getting the infrastructure bill
across the finish line it looks a little
bit more daunting
for the reconciliation bill
but
people are feeling it at home and that's
where that approval number goes
yeah i think so brett i think and look
inflation is really a dangerous thing
because it you know whatever
other gains are made in wages and so
forth are wiped out uh by inflation and
it damages your savings um as long as
the fed if interest rates are low it's
going to be hard for people to you know
to to who have savings to to make the
kind of gains that they want need
uh it's really it is about as corrosive
a factor in american life as one can
imagine and it has remained at bay for
many years now and here it's back and
the fed keeps telling us no this is
transitory and maybe it is
but if this administration is going to
have a anti-fossil fuels policy that
continues to drive energy prices ever
higher
they're not going to be able to convince
people that inflation is is under
control and it is the very kind of thing
that they're going to take out
on the party in power at the polls i
don't think there's much doubt about
that at all this is kind of politically
insane to let this go on and to shut
down pipelines and not approve pipelines
and end up begging saudi arabia to
increase its production to offset the
the loss of energy here at home i think
is not going to sit well with the public
no question about it yeah sure i mean
one of the first things president biden
did was the abandoning of the keystone
xl pipeline but then the nordstrom 2
pipeline over in germany and and uh
russia's efforts there went forward you
think that that is really a potent
political
uh
baton really for the republicans oh i do
well i think it is and look we were
really had achieved something quite
remarkable owing in a considerable
measure to fracking which was encouraged
and permitted under republican
administrations and which this
administration and other democratic
administrations in states around the
country have been have resisted you know
it's it's bar it's banned in new york
for example um and but but the effect of
it was to make us energy independent and
anything that suppresses that and
suppresses the flow of fuels from from
places where where petroleum is mined
and outside this country into this
country and flows on pipelines into this
country is only going to exacerbate the
shortages and and send the prices up and
it's
in my view it is it is it is probably
unwise energy policy and it is
absolutely crazy political policy all
right brett as always thank you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else